vamos a platicar de un par de conceptos
que muy seguramente te vas a encontrar
por el resto de tu vida y sobre todo en
tu carrera matemática esos conceptos son
los de rectas perpendiculares que voy a
poner aquí rectas
perpendiculares
circulares
lares y el concepto de rectas paralelas
lo voy a poner a la derecha
rectas rectas paralelas
paralelas y que quieren decir estos
conceptos paralelas
bueno pues decimos que dos rectas son
perpendiculares si el ángulo que hacen
es recto entonces déjame déjame hacer el
dibujo si tenemos una recta que viene
así y tenemos otra recta que viene
digamos así entonces estas dos rectas
van a ser perpendiculares cuando el
ángulo que forman es recto es decir
cuando ese ángulo es de 90 grados y si
uno de los ángulos es de 90 grados los
demás también van a ser de 90 grados de
90 grados vale entonces esto quiere
decir que las rectas son perpendiculares
por otro lado dos rectas son paralelas
en el plano en una superficie plana como
el monitor cuando estas rectas no se
intersectan en este caso se vería algo
así tendríamos una recta que va en esa
dirección y otra recta que va
exactamente en la misma dirección así
vale eso se suele indicar con una
flechita de esta forma esta recta va
para allá y esta recta también va
para allá entonces en este caso tenemos
dos rectas que nunca se cortan vale van
en la misma dirección es básicamente
como que una es una traslación de la
otra esta la puedes mover y que caiga
exactamente en esta de acá esto es que
sean perpendiculares esto es que sean
paralelas y si tienes dos rectas que si
se intersectan pero no en un ángulo de
90 grados por ejemplo algo de este
estilo una recta así y otra recta así no
se dice nada acerca de estas rectas no
se dice que sean perpendiculares o
paralelas bueno se puede decir que
simplemente se intersectan